welcome back to chapter 4
of how to speak so that people want to
listen
this is going to be quite a challenging
chapter actually because we'll be
venturing into the dark side
that's what i call all of the things
that get in the way of communication
effectiveness things that get in the way
of your listening and receiving in the
way you need to in order to send more
effectively and indeed things that get
in the way of you sending effectively in
the first place there are many of them
and as always it's becoming aware that
the crucial thing because if you become
aware of them you can actually do
something about them we'll start by
asking the question why don't we listen
and answering that there are many many
reasons in modern society why we stop
listening why we've not listened now for
some time as carefully as perhaps once
we did
we'll move on to the four leeches these
are crucial
aspects habits if you like which many of
us have i'm sure you'll find them in
your life somewhere and
again by becoming aware of the four
leeches we can stop them from sucking
the power out of our communication
we then go on to the seven deadly sins
which you may have seen in my ted talk
well that was very short and we have a
lot more time here to
unravel the seven deadly sins and look
at the way they affect
you in your life perhaps you're doing
them to other people perhaps other
people are doing them to you and with
all of these things we won't be able to
eradicate them completely we're all only
human however you can definitely by
coming becoming aware of them and by
doing the exercises that i'm going to
give you you can reduce their impact on
your communication
after the seven deadly sins we go on to
look at the agents of miscommunication
that's six things which
again powerfully affect us one way or
another and become tools actually if you
become aware of them
and finally we'll have a look at
vocabulary and some danger words some
words i really recommend you eliminate
altogether from your speaking so without
further ado
let's go back into the office and have
an in-depth look at the reasons why we
don't listen
okay so let's enter the dark side
first of all with the proposition that
we're actually losing our listening
i think this is absolutely true in the
modern world there are so many
challenges to listening and i think it's
worth going through some of them with
you right now
first of all we invented ways of
recording
things
thousands of years ago
there was no recording at all there was
no writing there was no audio recording
or video recording
and if you missed it you missed it if
somebody said something or taught you
something you have to listen
really carefully
now
the premium on careful listening has
really disappeared i mean look at this
course
if you go to sleep at the moment you can
always go back and restart it you can
check it again there's not much that you
can't check on youtube these days so the
premium on careful listing has
disappeared in most cases storytelling
of course is still around nevertheless
in most cases these days you don't have
to listen as carefully as you once did
then there's impatience there's lots of
research showing that attention spans
are relatively short
there was one very serious one a few
years ago attributed to microsoft but
not actually from them which purported
to show that human attention spans were
eight seconds less than that of a
goldfish well first of all i don't know
how you measure the attention span of a
goldfish and secondly that was absolute
nonsense the original study actually
said eight minutes not eight seconds
uh so these things do become kind of
urban myths nevertheless i'm pretty
convinced that our attention span is
shorter than it once was with this fast
edit fast cut lifestyle that we're in uh
we're used to advertisements cutting
every second or two it's just rapid fire
at us all the time
and in politics we are much more
interested in sound bites we haven't got
time for oratory oratory doesn't exist
anymore really it did up until the maybe
the 70s 80s in the uk there were people
who would stand up in the houses of
parliament and to claim and people would
come and listen to them because they
were such brilliant speakers not anymore
people just shouted each other and we've
seen that in politics all over the world
and think of the way that you consume
music now
when i was growing up i would play a
record and that was a piece of vinyl for
those of you who don't know
where you have to get up halfway through
and turn it over and then go back and
sit down you listen to it in order
it was a an exercising concentration
probably reading the back of the sleeve
as well now it's playlists tracks we
don't really listen to albums so much
anymore it's track by track or even
getting bored with a track the way we
channel hop as well uh when we're
consuming visual uh media the idea of
the whole country sitting down to watch
a program of an evening has gone because
we time shift channel hop watch bits and
pieces and so forth
a lot of younger people children are not
satisfied unless they've got two or
three inputs going at the same time you
know multiple devices and this is
becoming a well-known scenario in the
marketing world where they're having to
take cognizance of this and research in
different ways to find out
what attention people are paying to what
are they really watching tv or are they
chatting about the tv that's going on in
the background
then we have media sensationalism now
there's a merry dance well actually it's
a it's a macabre dance
between us
and the media
and the result of it all is numbing
it's desensitization
so the media love to use these
sensationalist words these are words
used by what's it called the red tops in
the uk the popular press which tend to
have red banners at the top of them it
doesn't seem possible for anybody to be
mildly annoyed anymore it's always fury
you go from zero to fury in no seconds
at all and that kind of dumbing down
unfortunately
diminishes our ability to hear subtle
understated
stories
hyperbole becomes the norm as we'll
discover in the seven deadly sins
politicians become celebrities not
states people
dialectic
rhetoric
where are they these days they've been
replaced by gossip largely so you know
the whole of life becomes a soap opera
where everything's got to be sensational
i think there are some journalistic
practices which are contributing to this
but we're also responsible so if i point
the finger first at the journalists
editorializing instead of writing
factual stories it's opinion opinion
attack journalism where people are
brought on to be interviewed and just
attacked
whatever they say which often involves
interrupting there's been a lot of
stories recently in the uk press about
the frequency of interrupting something
in the region of 18 seconds politicians
are getting and this is on you know high
level highbrow intelligent media not
popular media interrupting is enormously
prevalent
and cockfighting by which i mean
bringing on two people who are naturally
going to violently disagree with each
other and just setting them at each
other
to have a good fight
well that's easy it's lazy journalism
and it polarizes everybody and at the
foot of all of this kind of stuff
is an addiction to outrage
now there's a reason for that
and indeed
the blame hunting or blame throwing that
goes on
in modern society you know who's the
guilty party somebody has to be to blame
it's a seductive listening position
which we're going to deal with in a bit
more detail later on and it's called
being right
the easiest way for me to be right
is to make somebody else wrong and that
puts us on a bit of a slippery slope if
that's where we're coming from
where it starts with perhaps
caricaturing somebody's position then
polarizing them
and those very easily slip into becoming
prejudiced bigoted
hating people who are different and
we've seen the results of that around
the world unfortunately as you know you
disagree with me i kill you that is
no way to have civil society
so our fault in this is the being right
and the judging and the the blame
seeking the the media's fault in this is
their addiction to fast cut always on
24-hour news you know people standing
outside a house where something may have
happened yesterday
saying well nothing's happened today
well it's not actually news
but you know it has to be always on it
has to be immediate
now
that's
a little dire tribe on modern media
which are affecting our ability to speak
effectively and listen
because they pervade and they they
change our context and what's normal for
us
i think it's quite important to be aware
of that process
i mentioned headphones earlier on
headphones can damage our hearing
headphones can save us from noise
but headphones have a third very
important effect
and that effect is to turn large social
spaces into loads of little sound
bubbles where i'm in my little sound
bubble playing the soundtrack of my life
as i walk around or incredibly
dangerously as i see more and more often
cycle or even drive a car i mean that
it's illegal to drive a car with
headphones on it should be illegal to
cycle with headphones on because that is
just insanely dangerous
hearing is your primary warning sense if
you can't hear what's going on around
you you're desensitized now the research
shows that many people use headphones
for this reason to cut out intrusive
sound around them and that i completely
understand it's taking control again of
the sound
but at the same time you need to be
aware sometimes especially if you're
cycling of the sound around you so it's
a question of balance
talking of balance there's another
effect of
modern living which is something that
murray schaefer the great canadian
writer and musicologist calls
schizophonia which i think is a lovely
term it's a divorce between
what you're hearing and what you're
seeing
obviously the most common case of that
is headphone wearing these days
murray schaefer actually coined it to
describe the experience of sitting in a
room listening to a symphony orchestra
through loudspeakers because
clearly the orchestra are not there with
you
so you're hearing something that doesn't
exist physically or for your eyes so
there's this disconnect we're becoming
more and more used to this now
it's something that's used enormously in
in films where very often you'll hear a
sound effect come in before the visual
cuts to that scene and you get primed or
the music will change in order to tell
you something is about to happen they're
very clever with that in motion pictures
schizophrenia isn't in and of itself a
bad thing
but it is important to start to become
more conscious of this pernicious trend
to divorce what we see from what we hear
very often you'll be in a hermetically
sealed building it'll be raining outside
you can't hear a thing
so it it's disconnecting us from the
real world in some way and there's
something
which concerns me about living in that
state
i think it's quite important at least
part of your day to unify your senses
and be
surrounded by what you see what you hear
what you smell touch and even taste
being in unison
now let's move on to talk about
technology which i think is one of the
very biggest things that's
disconnecting us and getting in the way
of our ability to speak and listen
this kind of thing i'm sure you've never
sent this text and i hope you've never
received this text but it does get sent
and it does get received
that's not a conversation is it where's
the listening in that
it's actually an issue i've done some
work on this over the years and we've
done research which showed that people
are using different communication
channels so it's not any longer just the
issue that maybe young people have got
different vocabulary
to older people they're also using
different channels of communication
so the generation gap is becoming wider
and wider younger people prefer
text or instant messaging then there's a
sort of middle
group who prefer email and then older
people prefer telephone letter and so
forth those more old-fashioned
communication mechanisms are dying out
and when did you last send a letter
i receive very few i send none now
email of course is enormously dominant
and it drives this kind of text based
interface that we have with the world
our relationship is driven by our eyes
so much
so much of our communication comes in in
this way eyes and fingers tapping on
keyboards it
changes the way we behave a great deal
all of these things are very much in the
line of what i call personal
broadcasting fomo drives them we want to
broadcast with this fond fantasy that
the world is out there waiting on our
latest tweet or post or tag or whatever
it might be
tapping away i'm on a train
who cares
actually very few people and we we get
this kind of fantasy that we're the
stars of this universe where we're we're
broadcasting out to avid fans
now that's one way communication there
isn't a great deal of listening in those
media unfortunately and there's a great
book by sherry turkle professor at mit
and also a ted talker whom i've i've met
and she's got another book as well after
this one which is called reclaiming
conversation
sherry used to be a big proponent of
technology believing that it was going
to create this global village where we
would all be communicating
with each other
now she believes actually technology is
dividing us it's not bringing us
together
now it's not just us as individuals who
are poor at communication it's endemic
in the world
my next book i hope is going to be about
organizational listening and it's true
to say that organizations are terrible
at it i mean you and i know this how
many times have you attempted to
complain or get something fixed or get
through to somebody at an organization
they're terrible at listening they're
obsessed with outbound communication
and very poor at inbound communication
and i'm talking about internally as well
as externally
you know there's a balance between
speaking and listening isn't there and
unfortunately the research shows that
that balance is not 50 50 as in this
kind of zen diagram it's more like
this
about 80 20
speaking to listening in organizations
that's the balance of the effort they
put in the budget they put in the focus
that they put in and that was
self-assessed
so i would imagine that's probably
highly exaggerated most organizations
would like to think they're good at
listening uh most of them are appalling
at it and i think that 20 is probably
probably a big overestimate
we have got challenges in our in our own
listening and if i broaden this to talk
about things that we do ourselves so not
so much things that are external to us
in society the trends which are getting
in the way
the habits
that we have as human beings which have
been around forever of course
which get in the way these are holes in
the bucket of your communication which
you can
do something about because they're
internal to you
and there are four of them
i call them the four leeches because
they suck power out of your
communication here they are
looking good being right people pleasing
and fixing they all come from one
emotional route can you guess what that
is
using the word the dark side for this
would give you a hint because
the root of the dark side is the same
thing in star wars
it's fear
these four things all come from fear
let's
go into them in a bit of detail so you
can start to ask yourself do these play
out in my life
now we all like to look good
it's natural to want people to approve
of us and with all of these things it's
a question of degree i'm not saying it's
evil wrong bad or you should never want
to look good of course not
however if it becomes a dominating
motivation in your communication
that can become an issue it tends to
give rise to some behaviors which are
not particularly productive
for example what i call competitive
speaking
that is to say if i'm saying well i'm
going to greece on holiday this year the
other person might say oh yeah i've been
to greece five or six times
my little piece of joy
killed
i feel belittled reduced the other
person is aggrandizing themselves
trumping everything that people say
becomes a habit you know having to be
bigger better i'm sure that nobody
listening to this has ever claimed to
have
read a book they haven't read
we've all done that haven't we all seen
a film we haven't seen oh yeah
solzhenitsyn he's very good isn't he we
all do it a little bit
however when it becomes necessary to
trump other people and we start to
embroider that's where the issue becomes
much more relevant because people can
spot it and you lose the power in your
speaking
and there's another manifestation of
looking good
which is very very common i call it
speech writing
which is to say while this
inconvenient noise is going on in front
of me i'm composing my next
bonmo my next piece of brilliant
dialogue
speech writing
is faux listening
false listening
not real listening you're not actually
concerned with what's going on here it's
what about i'm going to say next
it often gives rise to the response yeah
anyway and then on to what i want to say
which crushes other people
makes them feel angry actually and
ill-considered
so speech writing is not something i
recommend
actually trust your mouth to come out
with the right thing when somebody's
finished speaking
and then a third manifestation of
looking good is the simple phrase
i know
i met somebody at ted who was talking
about having moved to paris
and was saying oh notre dame is
incredible and all these parisians that
she was in community with we're going of
course
there was this kind of insouciance about
them it was like uh losing face to be
impressed
it was cool to be unimpressed by
anything she realized after a while
that's just the way that community was i
don't know it's a whole of paris or just
the people that she was with but it can
become a way of being can't it and if
that's your way of being i know i know i
know
if you know everything there's a problem
because you don't learn anything
it's like the old story of the zen
master
who is visited by a learned professor
who says tell me about zen then
and the zen master starts to pour a cup
of tea and continues pouring the cup
fills
and the professor eventually says you're
spilling the tea the cap's full
and the zen master says if the cup is
full there's no room for anything else
by which of course he meant
if you know everything if you're a
learned professor and you think you know
everything and you're coming from a
place of judgment you're not really
going to learn very much at all
now there's a good exercise i recommend
for looking good you can try it on for
an hour a day a week see how you get on
a minute which is to say exactly what
you mean
not to embroider or trump or make it
bigger but to be precise
losing the hyperbole we'll come back to
hyperbole and when we're dealing with
how to deliver effective content because
hyperbole is very common
so this is a great little exercise and
try it on for a little while say exactly
what you mean without having to
exaggerate
second leech being right
this gives rise to some pretty serious
conversational disruptors
first of all the most easy way to be
right is to make somebody else wrong as
we've discovered and that is
really damaging to communication people
can feel it when you're making them
wrong when you're judging we'll come on
to it in the seven deadly sins
and it stops them from receiving
very much creates conflict
interrupting is another very common
result of being right
you know when you feel that somebody's
making an incredibly wrong point it's so
tempting and i've said already with the
journalists doing that it's becoming
much more part of society to be
interrupting people
i have an exercise for that in a moment
there's a great phrase from the american
author harvard hendrix you can either be
right or be in a relationship
but you can't
snuggle up with being right at the end
of the day so it's something to be wary
of the tendency the need to be right all
the time
drives a lot of conflict and it's very
divisive for relationships now i said i
had an exercise for you if you're an
interrupter
are you an interrupter hands up
if you are i have a little exercise for
you which is when somebody's speaking
and you feel the need you feel that
bubbling up of something that's got to
be said
take a deep breath before you speak
and you might just hear the other person
is still speaking
that's a really powerful exercise don't
bother counting to 10 or anything like
that those are a bit clunky just get
into the habit of
before you speak and then you might just
have the time to notice the other person
hasn't finished yet
another great exercise if you're in the
habit of
judging or condemning
is to reflect and validate what somebody
else
has said
so to say i heard you say this or so
what you're saying is this
and that makes sense i can understand
you know i don't agree with you but i
can understand how you got to that point
of view so validating what they said
saying it makes sense to me that you
would say that even though i don't feel
that and i don't agree with it that's
different
so
let's move on to the third leech people
pleasing
that is effectively saying yes when you
mean no or know when you mean yes
not being true to your values having
your barriers
invaded or just dropping them all
together and not
as a friend of mine once said standing
in your own truth
you know you might be really tired after
a day's work we're all going out for a
drink do you want to come
oh yeah sure
half-heartedly because actually what you
desperately want is to go home and have
a cup of cocoa if you're doing that in
order to be liked and to be popular
that's people-pleasing and although
again i'm not saying it's always wrong
it's nice to please people nevertheless
if it becomes a driving force in your
communication you become
less seriously taken because people will
know that you change your point of view
depending on who you're with
you change what you say how you are we
all do a bit of a chameleon act a human
being is a multifaceted entity and we're
different with our parents to with our
children to with our teachers to with
our students to with our colleagues to
you know whoever it might be
we will be slightly different in each of
those cases very few people are
absolutely the same everywhere
nevertheless if that becomes exaggerated
in order to make people like us
then you're not being true to yourself
now there's a great exercise here
i don't know if you've ever done this i
do recommend that you
maybe pause the video now or after this
chapter
take this on
write down your values
what are your values
it's a very good idea to know it amazes
me the number of people who've never
thought about this
if you know what your values are you
have a moral compass
you know whether that course of action
or that course of action is more in tune
with who you are as a human being and
what you want to achieve
it's quite nice if they
are easy to remember so i wouldn't
recommend you have 15 or 20 values
four
six maybe at the most
two or three if you're happy with that
as long as you can remember them
i like acronyms my values fortunately
spell and an easy to remember words i
remembered them through my whole life
and they are faith
by which i mean
not religious faith but just comfort
that all will be well
in the future faith in that things will
work out
love
and we'll come back to that when we talk
about the foundations of powerful
speaking and here i mean well wishing
acceptance
which is to say this is the way things
are and there are certain things i can
change certain things i can't the ones i
can't there's no point railing about
them so acceptance is a big part of it
and gratitude
so that's faith love acceptance
gratitude flag is the word it spells and
i know where i am with my values
i do recommend that you do the same
thing and write down your values what
you really believe in
so that you can have a moral compass and
that will create a lot less
tendency to people please if that's an
issue for you
final leech fixing
that is to say not allowing other people
to feel pain
it not being okay for you for somebody
to be upset don't be upset don't cry
it'll be all right please don't cry you
know sometimes people need to be upset
sometimes people need to express
i was brought up in a family where there
was very little self-expression it was a
very
serene
but somewhat repressed environment so i
have to work at this
i have people around me who are much
more expressive than i am and sometimes
that's uncomfortable
i have to work at that too
the exercise that i do recommend to you
if you know you've got
the same kind of background as i have is
to work on enhancing self-expression
allowing other people to have it without
getting involved
you know if somebody's in floods of
tears just holding them
and going i understand
not don't cry it'll be all right trying
to make it better
and if you are also not comfortable with
expressing emotion then you can do lots
of things like watch some weepy movies
and actually have a good cry and get
practicing at expressing things more
vividly than perhaps you're used to
extending your range
the
ultimate degree of that would be primal
therapy or something like that but we
don't all need to go that far
but it is a very powerful thing to do to
enhance your self-expression and allow
others to do the same
again fixing there's nothing wrong with
trying to make people feel better and
working on that but if it becomes a
driving force or if it's really not okay
for you that's somewhere to look so how
do the four leeches play out in your
life
take
a moment now pause this
chapter i suggest and do some writing
writing is wonderful just write about
how these four things play out for you
looking good being right people pleasing
and fixing
and i'll see you back in a moment
we're going to deal with the seven
deadly sins
which i spoke about on the ted stage we
have a lot longer now to go into them in
some more detail
first of the seven deadly sins
gossip
now by gossip what i mean is speaking
ill of somebody not present
there's no problem with speaking well of
somebody who's not there
and if you want to speak ill of somebody
who's present you need to take the
consequences of that and that might
temper what you say the problem with
gossip is that it plays into this kind
of malicious human spirit that we've all
got somewhere in us which is wanting to
judge other people and find them wanting
wanting scandal
now that very much plays into the whole
being right leech
where it's easy to be right by making
somebody else wrong it's easy to look
good by making somebody else look bad
so it's about lifting ourselves up and
pushing somebody else
down very often gossip of course
is actually untrue
very often it's completely false
the problem also with gossip is that it
makes somebody into an untrustworthy
bearer of news
the gossip is probably embroidered it's
probably third hand it's been bounced
around
and
very often it's incredibly damaging and
upsetting for people
the problem of course with the gossip is
you know the moment you walk away from
listening to the gossip which is
seductive and it's in all of us to be
rubbernecking at car accidents or
whatever it may be
however the moment you walk away from
the gossip who are they going to be
gossiping about it's you
so if you become a gossip or if you
involve yourself in gossip it's
degrading the power of communication
it's not true very often if it is true
it's malicious it's not well-meaning
there's an exercise i recommend to you
about gossip which
is to abstain
from gossip you try it for a day
and you'll find it's very difficult in
the modern age it might mean not reading
newspapers not looking at the tv not
listening to the radio not reading
magazines and not looking at the
internet
because gossip is all around us all the
time so much of news now is salacious
celebrity gossip
so it's very difficult and you may have
to walk away from your friends and just
say i'm actually i'm having a day off
doing this
which would make them look at you
slightly strangely maybe you could
enroll one or two of them in it if it's
become a problem in your social circle
for example
what is not going to work i can tell you
is to point the finger at other people
and to be right about this
saying to other people oh no i'm not god
you're gossiping i'm not doing that
that's just being right again
so you know be compassionate people are
people that's the kind of trees they are
that's the kind of people they are you
can't change other people by
pointing the finger and judging them
what you can control is your own
behavior
so i do recommend abstaining from gossip
for a little bit so that you become more
sensitive to it it's like anything if
there's a noise around you the whole
time you become desensitized to it take
yourself away
go back into it you go my goodness that
is what i've been in all the time
it's the same thing with gossip a little
period of abstinence will really help
you
to understand how
serious it is as an issue in your life
next of the seven deadly sins is
condemning now i think i use the words
the word judgment on the ted stage
what i really mean is condemning
judgment discernment obviously is really
really useful
you need to have it in your life is this
right or wrong is this good or bad do i
believe in this or not
however if you become a habitual
condemner
that is very damaging for your
relationships around you
so i'm talking about the kind of parent
whose child comes back and says i got 95
in the test and the parent says what
happened to the other five
you know nothing's ever good enough
everything is
to be picked apart to be criticized
i don't know if you've seen the film
whiplash
which is
quite a dark film about a young
would-be drummer and his teacher who is
a real monster in the film says there
are no two words more damaging in the
english language than good job
so he doesn't believe very much in
praise
so again here i would
reflect on this for you and we'll give
you the exercise of thinking about all
of these values at the end all of these
seven deadly sins at the end and seeing
if they're playing out in your life do
you
tend to criticize or praise is there a
balance in your life
next we have negativity and the story i
told on the ted stage is absolutely true
my mother in her declining years when
she was actually in hospital having
broken a wrist i think it was and i took
a newspaper into her now her worldview
by that point was
summed up as everything's awful
so she was undyingly negative about
things
oh the sun's out it'll be raining later
you know that kind of negativity where
it's really wearing and i took the
newspaper in said oh look it's october
the first and she said i know isn't it
awful well
if october the first is awful
what hope is there really
because there's nothing awful about
october the first that's a world view
which really doesn't serve and if that's
where you are it it kind of poisons the
present moment it's a projection of fear
maybe it's much more powerful to be here
now
across the bridges that you have got to
cross when you come to them
being present in the moment and having a
relationship with the moment which is
not colored by a fixed context like
everything's awful
everything is not awful
also
to paraphrase that wonderful lego movie
that my daughter enjoys so much
everything's not awesome either
it's not either awful or awesome it is
somewhere in the middle probably and
it's
possible to make up your mind about how
you feel about it
at all times
so the habit
of negativity is very damaging
then we have next door to negativity
complaining the british national pastime
really we complain about everything it's
relatively amusing sometimes
but i call complaining viral misery
it's again very much about being right
isn't it complaining about the
government the sport your useless
football team whatever it might be
having a go at somebody who's not there
and something that you can't do anything
about now i'm not saying never complain
if you're in a restaurant and you get
bad food complain send it back
absolutely you can do something about
that
but in life there are things you can do
something about and there are things you
can't do something about
you know you get a chance to change the
government once every few years
in the meantime that's the government
and complaining to people is just
dragging them down into your negativity
the
antidote to complaining would be
gratitude and just focusing it's a
question of where you put your attention
if you focus on the things that are good
in your life the things you have to be
grateful for
then life becomes much more pleasant to
live if you focus on the things that
you're upset about or that are giving
you some sort of pain
then life becomes unbearable
potentially
so complaining let's try not to do too
much of that
excuses we've all been this guy it was
my fault this happened this happened
this happened we don't like to admit
we're at fault again this is about
looking good
and you know you may be surrounded by
people you have people in your life who
do this not me
somebody else
throwing the blame around and absolutely
not accepting responsibility
that's not a productive way to be for a
couple of reasons first of all people
don't like it
if you just sidestep and swerve
responsibility for things when you've
made a mistake and secondly you don't
learn
because if you're saying this wasn't my
fault there's nothing you can do about
it you're a victim of what's going on
and unfortunately in that situation you
just won't learn anything
at all
so it's not a productive way to treat
mistakes
that's how we learn
you know there's a lot of literature now
about the importance of mistakes in
processes like innovation
if you don't make mistakes if you're
frightened to make mistakes or to take
responsibility for mistakes
then it's very difficult to move forward
actually because you learn very little
some of the greatest modern inventions
have come about from mistakes
that people made
and if you take responsibility for your
mistakes what you can do rather than
simply saying it wasn't me you can say
yes i made a mistake i'm very sorry and
this is what i put in place to make sure
that never happens again
so
admit responsibility take responsibility
and create a structure which is going to
stop that from happening in the future
and recommit
penultimate of the seven deadly sins we
have exaggeration
now i spoke earlier about embroidery
about
a practice of saying exactly what you
mean and this plays out here as well
again this is completely about looking
good it's become
i think very sadly necessary
to
push the envelope in conversation to
make things bigger more powerful
express more vividly and as a result of
this there's a kind of language
inflation going on
which i find quite distressing
i mean it's no longer enough to be
excited about something you have to be
super excited about something and
probably in a few years time super
excited won't mean anything so you have
to be super super excited
you see how it deflates the the meaning
of the original meaning of the word was
perfectly good
a lot of words have been repurposed and
dumbed down to mean just good like
fantastic amazing
excellent and these actually have
different meanings and they are very
important old meanings we don't really
have a word for fantastic anymore as in
coming from fantasy or amazing is such a
devalued word that it's pretty hard to
say that is amazing without sounding
like you're just saying that's really
good
and of course the big one of these which
i always castigate my friends in america
for is awesome and when i joked about
the lego movie which is ironically
saying everything is awesome
which was very funny
but if a pizza becomes awesome then how
do you describe
a beautiful sunset the word has gone
final of the seven deadly sins
dogmatism
which is confusion of fact and opinion
and i know that very well from my family
background where there was a lot of
confusing effects with opinions they're
not the same thing
a fact is
incontrovertible it's not a view an
opinion and when people start to believe
that their opinions are actually true or
fact
then a lot of table thumping and
argumentation results
i have a
wonderful fantasy of a world where
opinions are given by request only would
you like my opinion on that
no
oh
i had such a good opinion ready to go
we don't do that do we and you would
have to be ready to be very disappointed
when you have great opinions which you
want to give to people we don't do that
we just say well in my opinion
and that's kind of fine if we're
contextualizing it giving it a frame as
this is my opinion only my opinion it's
what i think
and it obviously comes from all of my
filters and my experiences
nevertheless if we start to believe
these things are true again we get into
enormous conflict and that's where a lot
of the competitive speaking comes from i
know and competitive speaking
so your exercise for the seven deadly
sins
you could leave this page out freeze the
video in a moment and just spend your
time writing
look at how those things play out in
your life who does them to you
who do you do them to who do you do them
with
and what you're going to do about it now
you've isolated that so for each of the
seven sins ask those questions who do
you do it to or with and who does it to
or with you
and what do you want to do about that
those three questions for each of the
seven you should have 21 bits of writing
at the end of this exercise
hope it's useful for you
now we're going to move on to look at
the agents
of miscommunication these are
stumbling blocks in the way and they do
not help again by becoming aware of them
you can do something about them
agents is another acronym
i have terrible memory so i love
acronyms and i hope they're useful for
you we'll go into each of these in turn
in a little bit of detail so you can
understand how they play out let's start
with assumptions the a of agents
assumptions are quite dangerous things
when they're
under the surface when they're implicit
and we don't realize we're making
assumptions
you know when i turn on a switch on a
wall i assume electricity is going to
work in some way shape or form i don't
understand i'm not a physicist i don't
think even physicists necessarily
understand everything about electricity
but um it will work and a light will
come on i have that assumption and when
that's pretty harmless as assumptions go
and it's normally correct
however we may make assumptions about
human behavior what goes on inside of
other people's heads is particularly an
assumption we tend to make and they can
be pretty dangerous i mean the most
obvious one
i've already mentioned to you is
everybody listens like i do
that's not true
and it's a commonly held
assumption
let me give you an example of how this
plays out in a scenario let's say
somebody's walking into a hotel and the
bell person comes up and says let me
help you with that bag
now i'll give you two different people
walking into the hotel
the first person has had a tough life
and has formed the assumption because of
being criticized maybe by one of those
judgmental people
a parent or somebody like that people
think i'm weak and useless
so the inference let me help you is i'm
being patronized and the response is
going to be a resentful response no
thank you i'm perfectly capable of
carrying my own bag
the other person hasn't had that
background their experience has been
that people are nice and kind so the
inference they're going to get from that
offer is i'm being cared for the emotion
will be gratitude well that's very kind
thank you very much
now this happens
you know the same input
two people with different assumptions
about what's going on behind that offer
and two completely different responses
to the same communication
that happens a great deal and it's
really important to become aware of the
assumptions that are actually driving
the way you communicate with other
people where you receive them and the
way you send back to them
the g of agents is generalizations i
love this quote from agatha christie
which of course is a generalization uh
it's an ironic self-knowing quote
but generalizing
extrapolating from
quite often one data point
something goes wrong oh it's going to be
a terrible day today we'll come on to
words which don't help the always the
maximizing words always never and so
forth
generalizing can be very destructive in
communication
and it's to be challenged sometimes it
may be
useful
other times it can be
extraordinarily confrontational and
destructive
so let's ask what assumptions and
generalizations
are affecting
your speaking
now that's not something that you can
sit down and write immediately you'll
need to think about it and it's probably
best thought of as a door opening into
an enquiry assumptions and
generalizations are things that very
often live
underneath our conscious awareness
and it's just a good question to be
asking yourself all the time what are
the assumptions i'm making and am i
generalizing about anything
extrapolating from a single data point
let's move on to consider the e of
agents that's emotions
i think there's a strong case to suggest
that emotion and listening upset and
listening at least are very inversely
related if you want to reduce somebody's
upset somebody's talking to you the best
way to do that is to listen to them and
conversely if you're upset yourself it
becomes harder and harder to listen to
somebody else
so that is i think definitely true on
the other hand there's a positive
correlation between listening and good
emotion and the more you listen to
somebody the happier they will tend to
feel because they'll feel heard and
understood and those are very important
in relationship
when you're upset it tends to be because
you've got some sort of a complaint
and this is where it's very important to
remember that my definition of listening
is making meaning from sound
so if somebody says something that you
find upsetting you could try to
disentangle these two things
there's what happened
and there's what i made it mean
they're two different things the what
happened is a fact that what i made it
mean is a story
and it's really useful to uncollapse
those two things and to remember that
you have the ability to make up any
story you like about things so there's
what happens and then there's the
question
is what i made it mean useful is that
the best thing i could make it mean
could i make it mean something else
that's more useful in my life
perhaps less upsetting less damaging
less debilitating or stopping in what i
want to achieve
so that's a very good practice to
uncollapse those two things and to
remain always on top of the fact that
you're making stuff mean stuff
all the time in your listening
and now the n of agents which is noise
if you have to work or communicate in a
noisy environment i recommend you take
an mba
the m stands for move
and that is to say as i've said before
just move yourself to a different place
you can always do that or almost always
do that
and it's amazing how rarely people do do
that if you can't move for whatever
reason
you're fixed in a certain place this is
your desk and you have to sit there then
your next strategy would be to block the
sound that's going to be headphones and
this is the beneficial use of headphones
where we can put headphones on with
useful sound that's less distracting
than other people's conversation or to
ringing phones or
whatever is around you and is getting in
the way of what you're trying to do
obviously block doesn't work very well
for communication putting on headphones
isn't the best way to communicate with
somebody else it is pretty useful if
you're trying to talk to yourself
in your head listen to the little voice
in your head that you need to listen to
when you're writing or doing mathematics
or whatever
and if you can't move and you can't
block the only strategy left is to
accept the sound which is to say let go
of the upset then not the anger i can't
stand this how am i supposed to work in
this place just let go of that say okay
i decide to be here this is where i am
i'm going to do my best and then just
get on with it in some sort of serene
acceptance of what's going on around you
it often is the upset itself which gets
in the way of your working productivity
now sounds to use if you're going to
block on headphones let me give you
three suggestions if you can guess what
these letters stand for
yes our good old friend nature sound
wind water and birds in moderation very
good sounds they've been around on this
planet forever
much longer than we have anyway and it's
very easy for most people to work to
those and they can
get you away from that distracting sound
around you if you put these through
headphones you can work very effectively
and you won't be so distracted another
alternative i can recommend is an app
that we developed from the sound agency
some years ago it's available on the app
stores
it's free it's called study and it's a
45 minute
piece of sound that's very good for
working to it was designed really with
children who have to work at home in
noisy kitchens or whatever in mind but
it works absolutely anywhere that you
have to work surrounded by noise pop the
headphones on use study and it'll also
remind you when 45 minutes is up so
it's healthy to take a break at that
point
okay on to the tea of agents and that is
time
listening and communicating take time
and it is really difficult if we don't
make time for it to have effective
communication if we're trying to do two
or three things at the same time it
doesn't work i really agree with this
quote from scott peck i think it's
absolutely
true and i also think tragically there
are probably billions of people on this
planet i mean literally billions who've
never had the experience of being really
listened to
because we're so time poor now it's such
a rare thing to put everything down
and give 100 of our attention to another
human being it's a wonderful gift
it's an enormously generous thing to do
and it's something we get out of the
habit of doing so we kind of part listen
all the time
let me give you a great exercise to do
here
really listen to somebody today tonight
after this course whoever you come into
contact with put everything down
and really listen to them we'll we'll
look at some exercises which will
improve your ability to do this very
effectively in the next section however
right now i think it's enough just to
ask you to put everything aside and
really listen and you'll be amazed i
think by the response you get
the s of agents is semantics semantics
are about meaning so here's what it
really is all about
you have a context for what's being said
obviously that's your experience or the
experience of the other person
everything you've done everything you've
remembered can color a particular word
and it could make it a word that you
hate a word you love a word that's got
particular meanings to you your filters
in other words
denotation is at the center
of
semantics denotation is the essential
central meaning of the word so think of
the a word like dog
so denotation of dog is a four-legged
mammal with a tail and blah blah blah
blah blah you know we all know what dog
uh kind of looks like can look like lots
of different things but we know what a
dog is
however
connotation is then the implications and
emotional associations of that
there was an advertising campaign some
years ago in the uk by a phone
manufacturer where the strap line was be
more dog
we know what they mean by that they mean
more happy and joyful and exuberant and
tail waggy and all that kind of stuff
so that's the connotation of the word
dog that they were using and then as
i've said there's the context for you
for me for anybody listening to this
which may have different connotations so
denotation connotation and context are
very important to understand all the
time people don't listen the way you do
and each conversation may have a
different context and the word may have
a different connotation
in that context with those people
so that's the agents of miscommunication
i hope that's been useful to you
words are very important if you don't
have articulacy it's very difficult to
express yourself and it becomes
frustrating and it means that you're
struggling all the time to put the ball
over the net to be understood to be
expressed in the world
and sadly the research tends to indicate
that words are becoming
less familiar to people
this may be the effect of text it may be
the effect of listening to things other
than speaking a lot of the time it may
be the effect of incessant viewing of
films or whatever on tv or the internet
whatever it is it appears that younger
people use less words than older people
and that is a bit of an issue now there
may be an argument to say well they
haven't had as long on the earth they
haven't learned as many words and i'm
sure there's part of that in there as
well nevertheless when you think of the
use of the word like
uh i don't think it's quite so prevalent
as it used to be a few years ago and i'm
like and he's like and i'm like and he's
like that
is scumming the language down
there are other words for to say
than and i'm like
and if you use the same words over and
over and over again it does tend to dumb
down your communication to make it
coarser
now i have a little exercise for you
here or three actually three good things
to do in order to improve
your vocabulary which is always a work
in progress i do it all the time
so reading absolutely crucial reading
good books
intelligent books that will help you
with your vocabulary because you'll be
coming across words all the time that
perhaps are not so familiar or used in
different contexts or just elegantly
expressed
you can get apps for all of your devices
which bring up words as a screen saver
that's really useful too
or apps that serve you a new word every
day to consider and then finally
crosswords i do the times cryptic
crossword every day i love it and it's
one way i try to keep my aging brain
fit and healthy i do recommend
crosswords whether they're concise or
cryptic it's up to you crosswords are
very good for connecting you with words
all the time get a good dictionary on
your phone or your computer as well
now there are some words which don't
serve and i'd like to end with these the
danger words the words i recommend you
perhaps don't use as one i recommend you
eliminate all together actually because
i can't think of a single profitable use
of this word and it's the word should i
honestly can't think how this can serve
in any way other than negatively i
should have done that i should have been
much better than i am you should lose
some weight should is
it's a judgmental word at its heart
it is possible to express things in
different ways i plan to lose some
weight
and i am going to do something about it
not i should lose some weight [ __ ] is
always
judgmental
and if you get people giving you shoulds
you can always say things like well
thanks and i wasn't really looking for
any advice about that or thanks for your
advice if you want to be really polite
or why do you think that
thanks for your opinion so i would
definitely attach a little alarm bell to
this word
and certainly attempt to use it less in
your vocabulary
now the next little word is a little bit
like bindweed it's very pernicious and
it tends to crop up a great deal in
conversation and it is a weakening word
in your speech
just i'm not talking about the adjective
he's a just man that's a wonderful word
i'm talking about the adverbial use here
as in
i'll just have one
how many times have we ever said that
and got into trouble or
she's just a secretary
which is a demeaning it's a diminutive
it's a reducing word
and actually when it's used in
conversation a lot of the time it's an
elided apology
i'd just like to say
there's a rather weak way of saying i'd
like to say
just in that particular context is it's
not much it's really small could you
please let me it's a very craven
connotation of the word in that context
the example i always give is walk on
stage and say i'd just like to start
with some housekeeping announcements
which sounds perfectly normal until you
compare it with walking on stage and
saying i'd like to start with some
housekeeping announcements which sounds
ten times as confident
apologizing to people before you ask
them something is a weakness
and it does not deliver your request in
a powerful way
the word just i will now start using it
incessantly because it's very pernicious
and as soon as you've said it once it
starts to crop up everywhere
another one that is easy to replace
actually is the word but
which tends to act as a roadblock in
conversation a great deal of the time
i like you but
you know that after the roadblock comes
the meaty bit
you can replace it everywhere with the
word and
i think pretty much everywhere
and you'll get a better result
i like you and
okay that flows and i'm i heard the
first bit and i can register that you've
got a suggestion for me do try that you
can do it as a spell check in anything
written just take oh there was just did
you see that
a spell check in anything written
take the word but search for it and
replace it universally
with the word and and just see ah there
it is again
and see if that doesn't improve the way
your prose flows
final set of words to really think about
are the maximizers
always
never
those words that come into an argument
and oh they really calm it down don't
they
not
you never listen to me what never never
that person has never listened to you
you always say that always
these words are generally
incorrect they're generalizations
in one word massive generalizations
and they tend to inflame arguments so i
do recommend that you
again attach a little alarm bell to
those and if you hear yourself saying
those question is that true
it probably isn't
so exercise on those where do these
words come up in your life
uh again take some time think about them
should just but always never where do
they come up in your life do you use
them to other people do other people use
them to you and what effect do they have
and what you want to do about it
now the final thing i'd like to cover in
this tour of the dark side the things
that really wreck communication
is
things that get in the way when we're in
argument
and we all have them
first buttons
over time we've had wounds we've had
hurt we've had rough experiences and
they become
buttons or they become
triggers
somebody says something quite innocently
to us and it reminds us of something
from the past
and out comes that pent-up anger from
years ago
completely inappropriate to the current
situation
now
there's not much you can do
to heal those immediately it takes work
it takes effort
sometimes it takes years
however becoming aware of them again as
always is the first
enormously important step
so what are your buttons what are your
particular triggers
and then outbound
we may have
barbs
that we
know how to use particularly if you've
been in a relationship for a long time
with somebody you know exactly where
their sensitive spots are and you can
unkindly
stick a barb in there at any time if
you're feeling mean-spirited or like
getting revenge or whatever it may be
so again
becoming aware of your
use of barbs and how perhaps you might
want to challenge that
and from time to time
there are also
the bombs that we can drop
really big things you know the things
that make the whole argument go nuclear
immediately
that insult
that reminder
that particular word or description
so
let's do a little exercise on those what
are your particular buttons and triggers
in particular
try to be clear also about your barbs
and bombs and perhaps restrain yourself
from using them because they don't tend
to help
in life and they don't cause
understanding and harmony
so
that is a tour of the dark side that's
been quite extensive i hope this is
useful to you i hope this has revealed
to you a lot of things that perhaps you
can take action about which will clarify
which will block up the holes in your
bucket
focus the power of your communication
and stop it from being
wasted and being poured away with these
things that can really
in so many cases that do
really undermine communication power
so there you have it the dark side the
reasons why communication is so
difficult in the modern world why you
and i may fall into these habits and how
to get out of them is what we're going
to be doing in the rest of this course
it's important to be aware of the
problems
and i'm going to give you solutions to
all of those problems including the
exercises you've already had in this
chapter of the course
we've looked at the dark side of
listening and how in particular
technology
plays out and affects our listening
abilities we've looked at the four
leeches
which are
looking good being right people pleasing
and fixing
we've looked at the seven deadly sins of
speaking and listening we've looked at
the agents of miscommunication and
finally we've discovered that vocabulary
is something we need to cherish and
nurture if we're going to be powerful in
our communication i do urge you to do
the exercises of this chapter to check
in with yourself and be really
scrupulously honest
in your self-assessment
it's very easy to be in denial of these
things and to have them operating just
below the surface
is really important to tease them out
and become aware of how they may be
affecting you in chapter five we're
going to move on to look at how you
listen consciously and then the rest of
the course will focus on sending
powerfully
remember
listening and
talking are intimately related and the
better you listen the better you'll be
able to speak and communicate